Je vois ces jeunes gens selon une perspective
qui considère les atouts qu'ils apportent au système d'éducation.
Donc allez-vous me rejoindre pour changer la façon dont nous étiquetons ces jeunes
de « à risque » à « prometteur » ?
(Applaudissements)
Comment puis-je savoir que ces jeunes
ont le potentiel et la promesse de changer ?
Je le sais car je suis l'un d'entre eux.
Vous voyez, j'ai grandi en centre-ville, dans une extrême pauvreté,
sans père,
il m'a abandonné avant ma naissance.
Nous bénéficions de l'aide sociale,
étions parfois sans maison
et souvent affamés.
A l'âge de 15 ans, j'avais été incarcéré
au centre de détention des mineurs 3 fois, pour 3 délits.
Mon meilleur ami avait déjà été tué.
Et peu après,
alors que je me tenais à côté de mon oncle,
on lui a tiré dessus.
Et alors que j'attendais l'ambulance,
pendant plus d'une heure,
il est mort, vidé de son sang, dans la rue.
J'avais perdu la foi et l'espoir dans ce monde
et j'avais renoncé au système car le système m'avait abandonné.
Je n'avais rien à offrir
et personne n'avait rien à m'offrir.
J'étais fataliste.
Je ne pensais même pas que j'arriverais à mes 18 ans.
Je suis ici aujourd'hui
parce qu'une professeure attentionnée m'a aidée
et a réussi à toucher mon âme.
Cette professeure,
Mme Russ,
c'était le genre de professeurs qui ont toujours le nez dans vos affaires.
(Rires)
C'était le genre de professeur à dire :
« Victor, je suis là pour toi dès que tu seras prêt. »
(Rires)
Je n'étais pas prêt.
Mais elle avait compris un principe de base sur les gens comme moi.
Nous sommes comme des huîtres.
Nous ne nous ouvrons que quand nous sommes prêts
et si vous n'êtes pas là quand nous sommes prêts,
nous allons nous refermer de nouveau.
Mme Russ était là pour moi.
Elle comprenait ma culture,
elle respectait ma communauté, mes gens et ma famille.
Je lui ai raconté une histoire à propos de mon oncle Ruben.
Il me prenait au travail avec lui parce que j'étais fauché
et il savait que j'avais besoin d'argent.
Il vivait en collectant les bouteilles en verre.
À 4h du matin, un jour d'école,
nous jetions les bouteilles en verre à l'arrière de son van
et les bouteilles se cassaient.
Mes mains et mes bras ont commencé à saigner,
mes baskets et mon pantalon à se couvrir de sang.
J'étais terrifié et j'avais mal, j'ai arrêté de travailler.
Mon oncle, il m'a regardé dans les yeux et il m'a dit :
« Mijo,
estamos buscando vida. »
« Nous cherchons une vie meilleure,
nous essayons de faire quelque chose à partir de rien. »
Mme Russ a écouté mon histoire,
l'a partagée en classe et a dit :
« Victor, ceci est ton pouvoir.
C'est ton potentiel.
Ta famille, ta culture, ta communauté t'ont enseigné l'éthique du travail
et tu vas l'utiliser pour te rendre plus fort dans le monde académique,
afin que tu puisses revenir et rendre ta communauté plus forte. »
Avec l'aide de Mme Russ,
j'ai fini par retourner à l'école.
J'ai même eu mes crédits dans les temps
et j'ai eu mon diplôme avec ma classe.
(Applaudissements)
Mais Mme Russ m'a dit, juste avant la remise de diplôme :
« Victor, je suis si fière de toi.
Je savais que tu pouvais le faire.
Maintenant il est temps d'aller à l'université. »
(Rires)
A l'université ? Moi ?
Mais elle a fumé quoi cette prof,
pour penser que je vais aller à l'université ?
J'ai postulé grâce à son mentorat et au soutien qu'elle m'a donnés,
j'ai reçu la lettre d'admission
et un des paragraphes mentionnait :
« Vous avez été admis sous un statut probatoire. »
J'ai dit : « Probatoire ? Je suis déjà en probation,
ça compte pas ? »
(Rires)
C'était une probation académique, pas criminelle.
Mais que font les professeurs comme Mme Russ,
pour réussir avec les jeunes
comme ceux que j'étudie ?
Je propose trois stratégies.
La première :
laissons tomber notre perspective déficiente de l'éducation :
« Ces gens viennent d'une culture violente,
d'une culture de pauvreté.
Ces gens sont à risque ; ce sont des voyous.
Ces gens sont des containers vides que nous devons remplir avec du savoir.
Ils ont les problèmes,
nous avons les solutions. »
Numéro deux :
donnons de la valeur aux histoires que ces jeunes gens amènent à l'école.
Leurs histoires sur la façon dont ils ont surmonté les pires malheurs
sont si puissantes
et je sais que vous connaissez quelques-unes de ces histoires.
Ces mêmes histoires et expériences
possèdent en elles la persévérance, le caractère et la résilience.
Donc aidons nos jeunes à travailler sur ces histoires.
Aidons-les à être fiers de qui ils sont,
parce que notre système d'éducation accueille leurs familles, leurs cultures,
leurs communautés
et les compétences qu'ils ont acquises pour survivre.
Et, bien sûr, la 3ème stratégie est la plus importante :
les ressources.
Nous devons fournir les ressources adéquates aux jeunes.
La persévérance seule ne suffira pas.
Vous pouvez me dire tant que vous voulez :
« Eh mon gars, prends-toi en main et relève-toi les manches. »
Mais si je né avec un t-shirt sans manches,
(Rires)
comment est-ce ce que je suis censé faire ?
(Applaudissements)
Apprentissage,
mentorat,
conseils...
Enseigner aux jeunes à apprendre de leurs erreurs
au lieu de les criminaliser
et de les traîner hors de la classe comme des animaux.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça ?
Je propose qu'on instaure une justice réparatrice
dans tous les lycées des États-Unis.
(Applaudissements)
Donc on a testé ces idées dans le quartier de Watts à Los Angeles.
avec 40 jeunes qui avaient été chassés de l'école.
William était l'un d'entre eux.
William était le genre d'enfant à qui on a donné toutes les étiquettes.
Il était en échec scolaire, un membre de gang,
un criminel.
Et quand nous l'avons rencontré il était vraiment résistant.
Mais je me suis rappelé ce que Mme Russ avait l'habitude de dire :
« Eh, je suis là pour toi, dès que tu seras prêt. »
(Rires)
Donc avec le temps,
avec le temps, il a commencé à s'ouvrir.
Et je me rappelle du jour où il a eu le déclic.
Nous étions un grand groupe
et une jeune femme de notre programme pleurait
parce qu'elle nous avait raconté l'histoire émouvante
de son papa qui avait été tué
et dont le corps avait été montré le lendemain dans les journaux.
Et alors qu'elle pleurait, je ne savais pas quoi faire,
je restais silencieux, j'attendais,
et William en a eu assez.
Il a frappé ses mains sur le bureau et il a dit :
« Eh tout le monde ! Câlin de groupe ! Câlin de groupe ! »
(Applaudissements)
Les larmes et la douleur de cette jeune femme
se sont transformées en joie et en rires,
sachant que sa communauté était là pour la soutenir
et William a appris alors qu'il avait un but dans la vie :
aider à soigner les âmes des gens de sa communauté.
Il nous a raconté son histoire.
Nous avons travaillé sur son histoire
pour aller d'une histoire de victime vers une histoire de survivant
qui a surmonté l'adversité.
Nous lui avons donné beaucoup de valeur.
William est parvenu à terminer le lycée,
obtenir un certificat d'agent de sécurité
et il travaille maintenant dans le district scolaire local.
(Applaudissements)
Le mantra de Mme Russ,
son mantra était toujours :
« Quand vous enseignez au cœur, l'esprit suivra. »
Le grand écrivain Khalil Gibran dit :
« De la souffrance ont émergé les plus belles âmes.
Les grands caractères sont marqués de cicatrices. »
Je crois que dans la révolution de l'éducation dont nous parlons,
nous devons encourager les âmes des jeunes gens avec qui nous travaillons,
et lorsqu'ils seront capables d'analyser,
d'identifier la persévérance, la résilience et le caractère
qu'ils ont déjà développés,
leurs performances académiques vont s'améliorer.
Croyons en ces jeunes gens.
Donnons-leur les ressources appropriées.
Je vais vous dire ce que ma prof a fait pour moi.
Elle croyait tellement en moi
qu'elle m'a amené à croire en moi.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)